thank you guys so much for doing this i
i really appreciate it of course
you're welcome um so we're just going to
chat about the amber ruffin show and
and late night and and seth's growing
library of impressions and
uh we'll go from there oh good we'll
have some some real honest assessment
from
amber i wish i had glasses so i could go
[Laughter]
well my first question for you guys is
about late night and
it you know i was wondering if anywhere
in the near or distant future do you
foresee ever stop
ragging on scotland no
i mean well i think that's a question
for scotland's right
yeah i mean is he going to change his
behavior
to the point that we won't feel the need
to try to get him to change his ways i
think that's fair
uh and maybe just keep having joel
mchale on oh my god joel mchale ragging
on scotland's the best it should be
noted that i
realized that scotland's was fair game
when amber also started ragging on him
amber would never
rag on someone unless they were so
safely
in the center of it
and once she once she unloaded i
realized oh this is total fair game
well amber you did something that very
few
humans in history have ever done which
is create and launch
a late night show during a pandemic and
i'm curious what that experience was
like for you because i was highly
anticipating the show but
i was not necessarily expecting it to
launch last fall you know in the middle
of all this
it was very fun
you know because it came along right at
the time where i was like oh
i would do anything to have an excuse to
leave the house
and then i had one and then i got to
hang out with all my little friends
outside of the house
it was absolutely i mean i feel like i
entered some kind of cheat code it was
so great
but then also there was no audience
so i never ever for one second
felt like oh i'm doing a bad job or
oh i chose a bad joke because no one's
there i was there to not laugh
you know i think a lot of people are
worried about oh well you're missing all
the sweet sweet laughter from the
audience
but what about the silence that's what
happens
yeah it's the true i can't believe more
people don't appreciate
that audiences can also make performers
feel bad
like like by the way like when we tell a
joke like we're
we are already the laughter's inside of
us like we thought it was
funny like you can either tell us we're
right or just
kill the thing inside of us i mean with
that said i'm
you know i'm blown away that amber did
this without
an audience that she launched a show
because i would say if there's ever a
time an audience that's helpful
it's at the beginning but i don't know
are you desperate for them to come back
amber
i truly have a horrible
memory and always have and i i'm
honestly like
how was it again what was it
i don't remember i truly don't and now
in this new thing i can't imagine
an audience in it i don't know it's
better it's worse
i'm doing the tonight show
tomorrow as a guest and i'm fascinated
what it's going to be like i feel like
when they laugh
my reaction is going to be we're trying
to have a conversation
two people are talking i was gonna ask
about that because i
i do honestly feel like both of your
shows benefit from not having an
audience now and
there's an intimacy there and maybe it's
just because i want to watch
it feels more insular or intimate
because you playing to
scotland's or shoemaker is funnier to me
than playing to
a general audience who maybe hasn't
tuned in doesn't know who's collins is
and
that joke is not going to land and
therefore you just kind of have
dead air but hearing like two laughs in
the back of the
rafters is very funny to me
it's very funny to me too and i do think
it has allowed us to build this weird
cinematic universe of characters on our
show
up to and including amber who just
during corrections is off camera
and the people who watch our show are
very aware that it's amber
and it is that thing of
i think the audience who came to our
show most of them knew our show
most of them liked our show probably
very few of them watched it every night
i think people who watch at home there's
a higher percentage chance that they're
tuning in
with regularity and weirdly that's
always been the most important audience
and and so
i feel more connected to them than ever
before almost
as a benefit like i feel like removing
that proxy audience that came every
night
has has uh has made it like a direct
a direct path to people at home so i
know colbert just got an audience back
do you
do you want an audience back are you are
you planning on bringing an audience
back are you pushing back against
bringing one back we're not gonna even
consider it
i think the early speed habit is uh
september to that end of that intimacy
and stuff i
i spoke to you last year from your attic
when you had just kind of launched
those shows which felt loose and silly
and i loved the quick pace of it
um and it kind of radically changed how
you guys had to do the show
and obviously then moving into the
studio with no audience it feels bore
loose and silly now
i was wondering for you do you or both
of you do you guys feel that difference
do you feel what the effect was
of having to move to the attic do those
incredibly silly shows with sandberg and
forte voicing
inanimate objects the impact of that on
on late night as a whole now i mean i
feel like amber
always was silly no matter what i
i don't think that it is uh the things
she brought to the table were always
the kind of fun and loose and that's why
i think they work particularly well
whether there was an audience or not but
i do feel like
i never would have known that would be
one of the byproducts of it but i feel
like this is the
purest version of what i think is funny
that i've ever
done on the show before and i would have
told you two years ago this is the
purest version but
you know you take out an audience and
and you
kind of force yourself to find ways to
perform
to no one and it's amazing how
liberating it is
the only people who have to think it's
funny is you
that's it it used to be like you and
them and
the audience and blah and the test
audience but now it's just you it's a
laser focus
of doofiness and you really learn
that your boundaries and that there
aren't
any yes right like we've like sort of
imposed these on these boundaries on
ourselves based on i think what the
structures of these shows have been for
years
and then you know for a terrible reason
we got to explore exactly what those
boundaries were and at least
there was fun in that sal was saying
yesterday
that he always felt like our show was a
sane
show for sane people and then we all
went crazy at the same time and so now
it's formerly same people who are crazy
doing a show for formerly same people
who are not crazy
but i thought that was a pretty good
that sounds incredibly accurate uh
well in amber for you you know how did
you decide on the format of the amber
ruffin show because i really love
you know has that silliness but there's
time to get serious the monologue is
really fun
but there's a playfulness that that runs
throughout the entire show
each time we really didn't think about
the structure
at all because we knew we don't have an
audience we're not going to get checked
for nothing
let's just do what we think is the
funniest
and then when we were doing that
we found like oh okay we're gonna do a
monologue okay
it's probably a song i swear to god i
thought i was gonna sing one song and
then
an adult somewhere was gonna be like you
have to stop doing that
no one said anything so i'm still
singing but like you know like that we
found out
oh there's um we should have like a
short
very goofy thing up top with tarik so
you know who tarek is and
you know very slowly this stuff is
falling into place
and it is the best science experiment
you know and we really lucked out
because we were like let's always
have someone say goodbye at the end and
let's always do a monologue at the top
and when you do those things you earn
all kinds of
goofiness and so that's what we do we
have those two bookends
to make it seem like we were being
normal but we were not
please keep the the songs and musical
numbers coming okay i mean you said it
i'll do it one day i also think that
you know it's not a format thing but the
thing that amber has always
provided so much value to late night
with is her ability to be
really upbeat and cheery and people like
her right
away and then she sneaks in
like a very terrible truth about the
world
that you were strangely more open to
receiving because it was coming to amber
and
i think that one of the most impressive
things she's done with her show is how
effectively that is just
slid over uh from our show to hers i'm
starting to think it might be more about
amber
than maybe anything that had to do with
us
thank you mommy i mean who would have
thought
we would be doing those little serious
pieces
we do a bit on the show called how do we
get here which is not unlike closer look
and it is the liggetty last
thing i would have thought i'd be doing
but to do it
i mean they turned it in i'm like oh my
gosh i love learning about this stuff
and now that's just a thing i like
they're incredibly effective
uh except you know a closer look has
become a staple of late night
but i was curious was there ever at any
point at the beginning or you know even
in the trump presidency
any push back from the network to
devoting so much air time to just like
discussing current events or like a deep
dive into politics
no i i do think by the way
had the audience not liked it the
network would have let us know
i do think they look at data and and
whatnot
and we just had really good retention
you know from the tonight show even
though our first act became sort of
a 20 oftentimes minute long
check-in with the base politics so you
know i i don't think a network is beyond
giving a note based on what you're doing
but i think more often than not it's
based on on how the audience is voting
so
fortunately for us our audience stuck
around once we started doing that and to
be honest
you know the feedback we got was it
seemed like a more
authentic version of my show when we
started doing that
as opposed to maybe more conventional
late night desk pieces well there was
almost an obligation for it to be about
trump every single time because of all
the nonsense that
his administration put through uh so
there was some
degree of anticipation once he was out
of like what would a closer look be what
would it feel like
did it did the creation execution of it
change at all for you beyond you know
swapping rudy giuliani for owen wilson
and vince vaughn you know that's a
one-for-one trade right there
everybody wants to see both um you know
that's something sally's even saying as
well like he doesn't miss trump but it
is really nice when rudy comes back yeah
um
i mean i think that the whole what our
late night show is going to do after
trump
kind of went a little out the window
because of covid and and
the the and the the fact that you know
trump's not over
it's in fact i think that's that's the
worst part
is how not over it is well we don't miss
him i wouldn't trade it like i don't
i don't want better jokes than him back
so right but i
you know so i think trump the idea is
still happening but you know i think in
a really nice way
that while our show was a lot about
donald trump for four years our show is
now
from a night to night basis more about
our show
i don't i you know it's not like naval
gaysy or anything like that
but i think there's a consistency now
in hey these are the kind of jokes we
like to make and we're also going to
talk about the news
but there's a freedom and it was always
our hope is that post-trump there would
be
more room for just silliness
cicadas
there's nothing silly about a giant
broadway hit true story amber you didn't
hear this i uh ran into christine
branski's
i did and i was with my mom who like my
mom just assumes everybody watches my
show
my wife should say my mom assumes
everybody watches corrections i guess
and so my mom says i hope you're keeping
your voice in shape for cicada cicada
and christie brazil's like whatever are
you talking about
but anyway she uh she signed up uh she's
going to do a minimum a year
[Music]
amazing um well into that point every
you mentioned how did we get here which
i think is a really wonderful segment
you said you didn't expect it to become
a
thing that happened every single show so
what was kind of the inception of that
and then
what were kind of the decisions that
went into keeping it going
there is this guy michael herriot on
twitter who
um will write these um
threads about history and it's always
some stuff you
had no idea about and it's always black
history
and it's always just great you know
because
the way it feels learning about black
history is so
special you know it's a part of you
that you didn't know existed but you
could feel it
you know what i mean and so those pieces
were
always so cool and i thought maybe we
could do something like that on the show
and then the first one he wrote
just blew my mind and then he was like i
got
these shits for days so he wrote
more and we loved them and then we
quickly had more than we had shows for
and we were like well maybe this is uh
every show thing and for now it is who
knows what's gonna happen
but yeah we did not expect that at
all but our show likes to just tell the
truth
and when people are
saying crazy things about black people
i love to say oh well here are some
receipts
for that ass you know so he
how do we get here is just a beautiful
way to do that and now it's become kind
of its own thing
so maybe we'll keep it forever or never
do it again
i love it i i say keep it coming oh okay
um you're in charge
okay okay well late night
as a format has always at least in my
experience whenever
terrible events happen in real life you
kind of turn to whichever
program is kind of your favorite to kind
of deal with what's going on i think
about
jon stewart on the daily show after 9 11
and you guys in the wake of george
floyd's murder turned
the show over to amber and i was kind of
wondering what the conversations were
that led to that
um and kind of i guess making that
decision and
putting that forth on on your show
because i i felt it was really powerful
and a really strong statement from you
all
when that happened i wrote a sketch and
i was like
you know at the end of the day i was
like ooh this isn't right
and then the next day i wrote a
different thing and i
at the end of that day i was like ooh
the tone changed
so quickly george floyd started a
revolution
and it took a two and a half days
and so in that time it went from
oh man here's another horrible thing too
the
world must change and so
i wrote that sketch and it changed and
changed and changing and change and
changed and then i was like you know
what i could just
tell a story i have and
seth and she were like great and i was
like well okay so the stories that
they're like
great just tell the story like oh okay
so i told my story it took as much time
as i wanted and then
it went well in the show and i said
uh after we shot it i was like i have
a lot of these so we can open how many
other shows you want
with stories like this for me and the
cops and i shouldn't say that the
true number is seven but seven terrible
stories is a lot of stories
there are certain things that happen on
our show where you know
we always think this will come across so
much better
if it's an authentic point of view from
depending on the story from amber from
jenny from karen from people who are
far more connected to it than i am and
you know it's a burden we put on someone
like amber at a time like that to say
hey this
awful thing happened you mind handling
it for us
and yet she came to us with
you know as she
said the tone was really hard to hit and
it was perfect and
we were so happy not that she had
seven total stories um
i mean four was ideal because that would
fill out a week but the the
the last three we felt were overkill no
but um
you know we we appreciate it as soon as
amber suggested uh
that that would be the right way to
handle an impossible to handle week
well i think it's a testament to late
night the show that it that didn't feel
out of place it's a
it's a different kind of late night
series and that it's not necessarily
about
kind of fluffing the the celebrities or
you know
playing games every week it's a show
that tackles current events
has that been you know i know you found
that groove pretty early on but has that
been kind of a guiding light in terms of
like what do we do now and how do we
address this
well the best thing that happened was
having a writing staff that also was
really good
at coming out as themselves and
addressing things
and the fact that that wasn't the first
time our audience saw them
you know if you it's
it's more effective if you're introduced
to say karen chee
in a segment what does karen know that
then when she
comes out to talk about violence against
asian americans you as the audience sort
of
know her as a friend now as opposed to
just someone who's behind the scenes
i'm really happy that we kind of had
laid the groundwork i mean it wasn't the
reason we were laying the groundwork but
you know we want you to know our writing
staff
so that you know when the time comes
you're willing to listen to them and if
there's ever
you know i think if there's ever
violence against you know white men and
tank tops that would be a time where
scotland will step to the forefront for
america
and get beat up i think that's perfectly
valid
amber i was curious because i know you
work on both shows how do you juggle
those responsibilities especially on a
show week when you're doing the amber
rough show the same week
well i always sometimes people go well
how do you decide which
this goes on says show and which thing
goes i
i when i think of the idea i pitch it as
quickly as possible
in my mind and i know this isn't true
but like the second you come up with an
idea it starts to die
so i like try as best as i can to get it
out there and so
usually on sunday whatever i come up
with i'll pitch on late night
and then if they take it great if they
don't
later on that same day i'll pitch it to
amber show
and then whatever is left over we uh
uh read on thursday so
i don't have it down yet
but also like there's not a whole lot of
it's not like seth was stopping me from
being my blackest
these people don't care what goes on my
show you know
a lot of times is fine can live on
seth's show
so there isn't a lot of like you know
like me and tarek see who can fart the
loudest
okay that maybe that can't go on
but lots of other stuff can depends on
who the guest is
amber is contractually obligated if
something happens in the news
and her initial reaction to it is to say
what
she's contractually obligated to do that
on our show that's the one thing
that we insist upon it happens a lot
well speaking of recurring bits i had
now that i have both of you on here
i've always kind of been curious about
the origins of jokes seth can't tell
what was the how did that begin because
that's become such a great recurring bit
well it's my story so i'd love to tell
you um
where
it started with jenny jenny was writing
all these lesbian jokes and bass
the head writer was like these are great
seth can't tell them
so that gave her the idea for her and i
to just write a bunch of black and
lesbian jokes
in a segment called joke seth yeah tell
and she
came to me with this idea and i was like
we should write it for the read on
thursday so that we can all
laugh because there's no way we can do
this on television
and then we read it everybody we doubled
over
i laughed loved it so bad and so then i
was like oh that was fun
it gets put in the show and i was like
oh no
we read through it was set at the end
seth goes
it's just like my grandpa always said
black women and lesbians are liars
and we are crying let me i go that's
so hilarious there's no way that is
going to be said on national television
we do it on tv though he's helped back
over the last musical lives
the audience is like
[Applause]
oh i was wrong this whole
way around the whole way around i had it
wrong but yeah
that's how it happened it was all jenny
and um
the audience will go with you on a
journey
i do it's one of the few things where i
acutely feel the absence of the audience
not the jokes that work but watching
even amber it's very hard for amber to
tell a joke
where no one will go along with her and
it happens a few times and joseph can't
tell and it's one of my favorite things
the thing about drugstore piantelle is i
will be like i want to tell this joke
and southern be like that joke isn't
going to do well and i'll go
you don't know and then i'll do it and
he's
never wrong and the audience will greet
me with silence
i'll look at them and seth will look at
me
and i'll do it again the next time ah
it's so i look uh a lot of times the
audience is peppered with my people
amber and i feel as though i have a good
sense
of their comfort level
hey i watched an old do you remember
conor o'malley used to do
anniversary guy yeah and we were
watching old anniversary guys
and he did the thing where he read off a
piece of paper
and he said the year was 2016. and he
said a couple things
and the punch and rachel dolezal was
making
america laugh with her race-based comedy
and there was a a black woman sitting
behind connor and she just went like
this
[Laughter]
so happy i sent it to connor i'm like
this is very you can use this
if the world never turns on you you guys
um
rachel dolezal was my number one
favorite punchline i don't think
anything will ever be that funny
because it's real it really happened she
was great at doing black hair
she did black hair every hairstyle she
did was perfection
and she was also horrible
okay she's my favorite so much so that
i had to get surgery and i was very sad
and the writer's room got a cameo
ordered a cameo from rachel dolezal
rachel told me that i was going to
compete
in the sochi olympics this is two years
after the sochi olympia
and it was not winter and she
she said her cameo amber your co-workers
are really um excited for you
to represent our country
in the olympics that's
my favorite present i've ever received
uh well i'm almost out of time with you
guys seth i am obligated to ask
is there any positive update on the new
season of documentary now
yes we're working on scripts uh we just
had a zoom call
that we were all gonna get on uh but we
had to reschedule it because bill had
forgotten it was his birthday
that makes sense that's the kind of
that's the kind of efficiency we're
dealing with over a talk now
great any sort of timeline of like it
hasn't been i'm sure it hasn't been shot
yet you guys are in the middle of
no we would uh the plan is to shoot in
the fall okay
yeah eagerly anticipating that with all
the other or i should say
criteria and collection approved
documentary now twice now
i think uh uh yeah i think co-op is on a
dvd extra now and i think um
uh globesman yeah has a dvd extra as
well
yeah um well finally i wanted to ask you
guys i know you're both
fans of each other's work and i was just
curious if you both would
um if you had a favorite thing about
each other's show if you
wanted to share that yeah i would say my
favorite thing about
late night seth i mean it
crazy and never went back like i can't
wait to see
and you know we joking we didn't go seth
is like i know seth so i know that he's
very wild and goofy
and now i feel like everybody knows
because he just let it loose and
that i think is my
favorite new thing like corrections as
much as it's a horrible idea
and terrible and bad for him as a human
being and spirit
um it is him in his
natural state and a lot more of that you
know was coming through unless he
captain
and uh goofy stuff and scotland's
burning and cicada cicada
you know all that stuff is shining
through now
and i cannot wait to see how
it um how it's gonna live
with the audience like what's gonna
happen are they gonna let you act like
this
what are the rules i can't wait i'm
gonna have a i'm gonna
bring a a plastic it won't be a real gun
but i'll uh
every time they don't laugh at a bit i'm
just gonna point at my head
[Laughter]
i can't wait to see corrections with an
audience
oh well we'll never do corrections for
an audience i'm getting them straight
out of there
um i uh not to harken back but how do we
get here
is uh for me a perfect distillation
about what i love about amber
and i think there's really a better
thing and amber has talked about this
before
every time something terrible happens
it's black people white people
will call her and ask her
how they should think about it or what
they should do is that accurate amber
a little bit and it's really unfair to
ask that of someone and yet
that's what amber is kind of doing and
that is what
i appreciate is it's not fair for her to
have to
walk us through things like that
especially really difficult things
but no one is better to go on that
journey with
and she did it with her fantastic book
that she wrote with her sister
lacey which i highly recommend to
everybody um and so while it's not fair
to ask amber to do that it
is not surprising to me that amber would
take that on and do that for all of us
yay and that's how we got here
gross thank you guys
so much for doing this i i'm such a huge
fan of your work
and uh both of your shows have been kind
of a nice balm uh during a tough time
for a lot of people
especially as they just got increasingly
insane so
yeah well um if i can have the last word
this has been a closer look